the cuomo brothers q-tip interview was
in poor journalistic taste wait until
you hear
this one a new report says top anchor
chris cuomo took part in strategy
conference calls with his governor
brother
on how to respond to sexual harassment
allegations
cnn giving us a statement saying that
chris cuomo
has stopped covering his brother on air
and added quote it was inappropriate to
engage in conversations that included
members of the governor's staff which
chris
acknowledges he will not participate in
such conversations going forward
jesse what do you think of that
i think they have three problems one
they should never have tagged cuomo as a
journalist at cnn he's not a journalist
he's an opinion guy and if you tag
someone as a journalist then yeah they
have to abide by
very strict journalistic guidelines if
you're an opinion guy
you could maybe tell a politician hey
watch out for the fake news
it's a different dynamic the second
thing is i completely understand
helping your brother out he's your
brother you're going to help him out
but now the stench of cuomo the elder
has gotten on cuomo the younger and that
stench is now wafting down the hallways
at cnn
and that is also the problem the third
problem is staffers at cnn are going to
hate this
especially female staffers and that's an
internal problem that they're going to
have to deal with
i did find it ironic that cuomo on his
show has mocked the idea
of cancel culture yet advised his older
brother
to use cancel culture as an excuse to
make his problems go away
he does seem like a golden boy over
there at cnn i looked up
i don't know he was in 29th place on
tuesday
no one's watching his show for some
reason he's protected over there
maybe he's just a really nice guy 29th
but who's counting
kennedy you gotta have a take on this
one i think they're both meatheads
and i think it's reprehensible and they
obviously uh skipped
the lesson in ethics they should be
ashamed of themselves
the reporter who asked governor cuomo if
he had the
the blood of dead new yorkers on his
hand if this book was written on the
backs of dead new yorkers and
he snapped at them and said you know
these are lessons that we should learn
from the pandemic yeah the first one
is don't put covid positive patients in
nursing homes
with healthy people who then succumb to
the illness and die
he hasn't taken responsibility for that
or the sexual harassment allegations
he's blamed his accusers
and if that's the advice his brother is
giving him they should both be
ashamed of themselves kdp
so we all know that governor cuomo has
bad judgment
but the idea that he would call his
brother chris cuomo when he has all of
these resources
you know lawyers to talk to the
government of new york to talk to about
handling the situation
and the fact that they weren't smart
enough to just maybe have a personal
phone call rather than jumping on a
conference call to give this advice
where there were other people listening
and they could just say that this was
going
on again shows that their judgment is
really bad
and if this were happening at another
network with this massive conflict of
interest on a basic level with chris
cuomo being related to the governor and
having to cover
uh the city of the state of new york
that's a conflict by itself but you add
all this other stuff in there
and you do wonder what jesse said why
did they continue to
protect him in this way one that is
actually a great point that katie makes
which is
um i can understand wanting to talk to
your brother if this happened but
to do it with government staffers on the
phone that seems weird
bad judgment yeah i was wrong
you know i mean it's hard to condemn a
man who wants to
help his brother i mean blood runs deep
you know
but and in the cuomo family politics
and media i think are a family business
uh but clearly this crossed the line in
terms of journalistic ethics he should
never have been on that call he
acknowledges that and said in the
statement and says
that he wouldn't do it again i think it
did hurt and it's going to hurt him
and his standing you know in this
business to do that it's just sad
all right juan thank you up next